welcome back or now we're going to start
a new section this is going to be
section six that starts on page 407 of
the official SAT study guide let's get
started with some problems so let's see
this first problem and the first problem
just so you know they tend to be tricky
but really fast problems and sometimes
they're just really easy and fast but
they tend to be problem that you should
be able to get hopefully in a few
seconds so if it if you're if you're a
plan of attack
immediately that tells you it'll take
you three or four minutes your plan of
attack might be non optimal it may be
correct but non optimal so the first
question is X plus 2 over X is equal to
5 plus 2 over 5 and I was actually just
looking at this problem right before we
started this video and well anyway this
is a pretty neat problem because this
falls into the category of there's two
plans of attacks here one will take you
some time and involves quadratics the
other plan of attack is ultra fast so
this is they say okay if X plus 2 over X
is equal to 5 plus 2 over 5 then X can
equal which of the following and they
give some choices they give the choice
1/5 they give the choice 4/5 to give the
choice 1 5 over 2 and 5 right these are
the choices they give so if you know
when you see this on an algebra test
your natural reaction is well let me
solve for X and so let's see you would
add 5 plus 2/5 you get some fraction
there what are you get 27 over 5 you'd
multiply both sides by X you'd get x
squared plus 2 is equal to 27 over 5x
you'd have a quadratic you would want to
factor that or use a quadratic equation
etc excentric sir that would take you
some time and considering this is the
first problem that's not going to be the
plan of attack so let me ask you do you
see a pattern here
do these two sides look the same well
they kind of do right we have an X here
and next year well we have a 2 here
right the 2 we have a 2 in both places
we have a plus in both places and but
the only difference is wherever I see an
X on this on the left hand side I see a
5
on the right hand side so does something
jump out at you well sure if I just
replace X with five this it's going to
equal this right because if I just put
five x equals 5 you get 5 plus 2 over 5
is equal to 5 plus 2 over 5 so this is
the answer so it could have literally
taken you about two seconds and I have
to admit when I first looked at this I'm
boy this is the putting of the first
question is a quadratic and said that
can't be the way and I looked at a
little bit longer about three seconds
longer and I said oh this is just
pattern matching let's move on to the
next question
image image image invert colors okay so
they have a right triangle here let me
draw the right triangle right right not
a wrong triangle or a right triangle
well you get the idea get the paint tool
I'll draw this edge now what's my
freehand my shaky free end and they say
this side is to decide is why this side
is X and this is of course is the
hypotenuse and it's in the right
triangle above if X is equal to 3 so
they tell us X is equal to 3 what is the
value of y well this is just straight up
Pythagorean theorem right this is the
hypotenuse Y is the pie potenuse so Y
squared is going to equal this side for
2 squared plus this side 3 squared so Y
squared is going to equal 4 plus 9 Y
squared it's going to equal 13 Y is
equal to the square root of 13 and that
is choice a this was just straight-up
Pythagorean theorem not nothing tricky
they're just kind of got a Chuck through
it I'm assuming I didn't do something
wrong well anyway let's let's assume
that and then move forward image clear
image invert colors I will now switch
colors for the sake of variety okay
number three number three
which of the following okay it says all
numbers that are divisible by both 2 & 6
are also divisible by 4 right okay
that's cool
which of the following numbers can be
used to show that the statement above is
false so they're saying all numbers that
are divisible by both 2 & 6 so if
divisible by 2 & 6 so this is what the
statement is saying then it means that
you're gonna be divisible by 4 right so
we want to prove that this statement is
wrong so we have to find is some number
that's divisible by 2 & 6 that's not
divisible by 4 so it's not difficult by
4 and we could actually just look at the
choices they give us the choices 4 8 12
18 24 well four isn't even if it's by 2
& 6 so that doesn't work 8 isn't even
divisible by 2 & 6 that doesn't work 12
is divisible by 2 & 6 but it's also
deserve life 4 so it doesn't disprove
this statement so we can't say that 18
well sure 18 is divisible by 2 & 6 right
is it divisible by 4 No so this is our
answer
18 the the example 18 is an example of a
number divisible by 2 and 6 and is not
divisible by 4 so this proves that this
is an incorrect statement number 4
number 4 in the figure above well let me
draw this figure above and I will switch
colors this is my rectangle and then
there's gonna be a circle
and the circle looks something like that
[Music]
oh look at that okay and then we have
sides a oh no no this is side b b a c
and d and it says in the figure above
the circle is tangent to sides B BC and
AD tangent means it just touches at one
point right of the eight by twelve
rectangle ABCD so they're saying this is
an eight by twelve rectangle and if it
approximately drawn us well we can
assume that this is going to be the
eight side and that this is the twelve
side because it's longer what is the
area of the circle well what's the
formula for area of a circle
it's area is equal to PI R squared where
R is the radius of the circle so let's
draw that radius of a circle so the
radius of the circle is gonna be this
line right here right this line well
there you go
right that's the radius which is half
the diameter what's the diameter well
the diameter is this whole length so the
diameter is 8 right so the radius is
going to be half of 8 so we know the
radius is 4 and then we just use the
formula we know this is gonna be 4
because this is also 4 right this is
also 4 because its side is 8 so we don't
even use this this top side could have
been not 12 billion units wide and it
wouldn't have mattered right so we know
the radius is 4 so we say area is equal
to PI times 4 squared area is equal to
16 PI and that is choice a all right the
next problem looks like it's more
involved and I only have two minutes
left in this video so I will do it in
the next video I'll see you soon